يعتبر من اهم الرياضات التراثيه هنا في
محافظه شمال سيناء فهو مرتبط بالموروث
الثقافي لدى العرب منذ قديم الازل
يا جعل المولى يحمينا
ندعينا
وبمناسبه الاحتفال بذكرى تحرير سيناء
وايضا العيد القومي لمحافظه شمال سيناء
اقيم هنا في العريش سباق للهجن في فعاليه
كبيره بمشاركه عدد كبير من الفنانين
والمسؤولين بعد القضاء على الارهاب في
المنطقه فيما اعتبرها الحاضرون اشاره الى
عوده الحياه الى طبيعتها في هذه البقعه
الساحره الحدث اقيم بالتعاون بين مجلس
القبائل والعائلات والحكومه المصريه بسباق
الهجن هي بالنسبه لنا التراث وبالنسبه لنا
اهم رياضه لان احنا ما عندناش يعتبر الكره
القدم والحاجات لان دي بالنسبه لنا اهم
رياضه ودي ترمز الجمل ده يرمز للصحراء
ويرمز للصبر
وقبائل سيناء او قبائل بصفه عامه تحب
السباق الهجن والهجن بالاخص لانه الهجن هو
اللي علم ابن سينا الصبر على العيشه في
الصحراء شارك في السباق الابل وصلت
اعمارها الى ثلاث سنوات من الاناث او
الذكور
[موسيقى]
للجذع الثنايا
وزمل من كل محافظات مصر المشتركين او
قبائل مصر تنافسوا في السباق خمسه عشره
قبيله من مختلف مدن شمال سيناء كما تمت
زياده قيمه الجوائز واضافه تقنيه الفار في
التحكيم على غرار مبارات كره القدم طبعا
يعني دي رساله الاهلي العريس ان الدنيا
تمام والامن رجع والامان
وبنقول للناس اللي جايه من بره يا مرحبا
بكم في اي وقت يعني خلاص البلد فتحت
وعايزين الناس تيجي والرجل تيجي والسياحه
تفتح اصلا سباق دي عاده اساسا عند البدو
في شمال سيناء يعني يعتبر الرياضه
الاساسيه في شمال سيناء فدي ان هي ترجع
تاني فده في حد ذاته ان شاء الله لمردود
على شمال سيناء يعني ايه ان شاء الله حاجه
محترمه باذن الله الحدث كان له اثر كبير
على اهالي سيناء بعد سنوات من شعورهم
بالعزله سمر بشات لصباح العربيه من العريش
بمحافظه شمال سيناء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات